Ja letztlich hat sich eine premiere da habe ich bei open mind super youtube-kanal unbedingt abonnieren
Ein t shirt bestellt und mit bitcoins bezahlen ging ziemlich easy wer die. Kripo währung bitcoin anfang des vergangenen. Jahres gekauft hatte
Konnte, einen bitcoin ende des jahres 2017 für den. Neuen zehnfachen wert weiterverkaufen doch
Dann, brachen die kurse. Ein aber fest steht auf jeden fall crypto währungen sind im alltag angekommen und sind in der wirtschaft
Und auf dem welt finanzmarkt ernst zu nehmen welche technologien stecken dahinter. Und wird es bald. Wohl eine globale crypt bewährung
Geben, das alles und noch viel mehr jetzt in kriegs. Und science fiction herzlich willkommen
Ja ihr habt euch dieses thema bei whatsapp gewünscht und vielen dank. Dafür wenn. Ihr bei whatsapp
Und jetzt auch mit den. Anderen messengern facebook messenger instagram kilogramm. Dabei sein wollt ans erfahrt
ihr und mitmachen wollt ihr bei klicks, um das er fragt, er am ende des videos kurz gesagt sind clip bewährung
Digitale zahlungsmittel und haben bis auf wenige ausnahmen eins. Gemeinsam sie, basieren auf der technologie
Namens blog chain übersetzt datenblock ketten es ist eine art digitales register oder kassenbuch dass alle transaktionen
Aufzeichnet also sowas wie teilnehmer hat die summe xy an teilnehmerinnen b gesendet blog janes kann
Man quasi als eine art technische. Handelsplattform. Bezeichnet die die teilnehmerinnen
Und teilnehmer von transaktionen unabhängiger macht und es gibt viele vorteile
Beispielsweise ist es für alle teilnehmerinnen. Und teilnehmer transparent
zudem sind blogs
Dezentral dass einer der wichtigsten vorteile das bedeutet dass staatliche institutionen wie die zentralbank beispielsweise nicht in das system
eingreifen können zudem sind sie fälschungssicher
Und an 24 stunden sieben tage die woche für jeden offen
Und verfügbar die demokratisierung des finanzwesens ist damit realität geworden crypto
Währung werden von computern nach wirklich komplizierten formeln berechnet mining
Bezeichnet die elektronische erschaffung des zahlungsmittels kaufen kann, man bitcoins an einer der vielen bitkom börsen mit ganz
Herkömmlicher wäre übrigens wenn. Man. Bitcoins usw besitzt kann man damit in immer mehr internet shops
Dienstleistungen oder güter wie bei open mind zum beispiel unbedingt abonnieren kaufen genauso aber auch
finanzmarktgeschäfte durchführen erfunden wurde dieses konzept einer digitalen währung übrigens 2008
Und zwar von einem software entwickler mit dem pseudonym sagt uschi nakamoto
Niemand weiß wer wirklich dahinter steckt es gab. Gerüchte dass der
Tesla chef elon musk. Sein könnte doch der dementierte die gerüchte
Ja bitcoin ist wohl das bekannteste cocteau. Geld aber mittlerweile ist davon die schon die zweite
Und dritte generation am start der gibt es währung wie kawano tron oder
Crypt bewährung gelten vor allem für viele. Jüngere
Anlegerinnen und anleger als alternative zu gold anleihen oder aktien doch als anlegerinnen. Und anleger auf dem markt gibt es ganz andere
Kriterien zu beachten, und zwar weil so schnell gehandelt wird beispielsweise was die steuer angeht steuerfrei können. So genannte
veräußerungsgewinne einbehalten werden wenn man bitcoins eine lange längere zeit als ein jahr hält wenn sie dagegen innerhalb einer kurzen frist
Kauft und verkauft muss die erträge versteuern und auch viele technologie start ups finanzieren durch diese digitalen münzen
geschäftsmodell und so gibt es weltweit bereits mehr als
1.500 crypto währung aber
Warum kann, man einfach so geld machen warum wird privat hergestelltes geld überhaupt akzeptiert dazu muss, man
sich vor augen führen wie normales geld funktioniert die basis ist nämlich total simpel vertrauen solange die menschen vertrauen das sie für
ihr geld waren und dienstleistungen in einem bestimmten wert erhalten funktioniert das system
Alle haben, sich quasi darauf geeinigt diese, währung zum beispiel den euro oder den dollar zu akzeptieren allerdings ist ein solches system
Empfindlich heutzutage gibt es notenbanken dieses system kontrollieren, um den wert zu erhalten in den zwanziger
Jahren, hat das zum beispiel in deutschland gar nicht funktioniert am ende hat dort ein laib brot mehr als achtung
100 milliarden marke kostet das vertrauen war dahin geld kann man übrigens auch selbst machen
Und das spielt vertrauen auch
Eine rolle zum beispiel mit einem schuldschein wenn ich auf ein stück papier schreiben das ich max 100 euro schulde und das
Unterschreibe habe ich. Eine art geld ich bürger mit meinem namen
dafür dass dieses stück papier
100 euro wert ist wenn es mir aber jetzt wirtschaftlich schlecht geht dann wird dieses papier auch weniger wert denn die
Leute zweifeln. Daran vertrauen dass sich das auch bezahlen
Kann es ist also eigentlich ganz simpel wie geld von trainiert, und bei crypto
währung wird das vertrauen durch die technologie
Hergestellt aber wir haben anfang mitbekommen habt ist dieses vertrauen auf schwankungen unterlegen deshalb wird
Immer wieder diskutiert ob es eine strengere regulierung von krippe währungen
geben, soll die deutsche bank beispielsweise fordert dass finanzbehörden in deutschland
Und weltweit jedenfalls sind sich diesbezüglich also der regelung zum umgang mit clip bewährung nicht. Einig in deutschland ist es sagen
So dass kein
datenaustausch zwischen den
Börsen für coop bewährung und den finanzbehörden stattfindet so können behörden den handel mit krupp bewährung nicht direkt nachvollziehen wie etwa käufe
Und verkäufe eines aktiendepots bei der banken hat sich ja bereits die zweite generation der krypto, währung angesprochen es
gehört wohl dazu
Und auch hier lassen sich virtuelle münzen von a nach b überweisen genau wie beim bitkom doch das ist mehr als ein reines
Zahlungsmittel ist ist gekoppelt an sogenannte smart contract. Also eine art
Intelligenter verträge die erfüllt werden wenn es definierte kriterien. Also wenn die eintreten beispielsweise kann
Ein, solcher smart contract das grundbuch von immobilien abbilden heißt also im klartext nicht nur der kaufpreis für ein haus wird vom personal
Nach person b ausgetauscht sondern gleichzeitig eben auch die eigentumsrechte beider parteien also
Das hat es bisher noch nicht gegeben mit der bezahlung ist automatisch. Dann das eigentum. Übergegangen die, währung namens esser hatte im
Januar 2018 fast das 5 130 fache seines ausgabepreises. Er zahlt das erzählt. Das kann sich natürlich schnell wieder ändern aber
Kommen wir zur dritten generation dazu gehört zum beispiel. Tron ende mai will tron dsc
Um plattform verlassen und eine eigene blog chain namens maine et
Veröffentlichen vor allem in asien will tom punkt. Und zwar mit in game
Und in app käufen auch die veröffentlichung eigener inhalte steht auf der agenda zudem planten auch
Ein dezentrales internet an dem jeder teilnehmen kann. Ohne zensur einer zentralen instanz
2027 soll die entwicklung von tron abgeschlossen geschlossen sein wie wird es wohl mit crypto
Währung weiter gehen werden sie in der zukunft. Tatsächlich das gute alte geld wie wir es kennen. Komplett ersetzen davon ist gary cohn der
ex-präsident des investmentbanking unternehmens goldman sachs überzeugt seiner meinung nach block chain
Ein riesiges potenzial nicht aber der bitcoin selbstzitat ich denke wir werden eine globale crypto
Währung haben die die welt versteht warum. Dann bin ich wirklich gespannt wenn. Er als erstes neues zur crypto, währung oder blog chains
Und zu allen anderen themen erfahren wollen dann endet. Meine telefonnummer hierbei whatsapp wenn. Ihr wollt könnt. Ihr? Euch da
Auch mit zehn gramm instagram oder dem facebook messenger mit mir verknüpfen kann erfahrt
Ihr von mir vor allen anderen vom neuesten video täglich garantiert er, konnte dort direkt über mich in der redaktion prächtig
So mitmachen themen vorschlagen und so weiter. Und so fort einfach hier draufklicken. Und zur begrüßung habe ich. Ein kleines goodie
Und natürlich nicht das awo mit der
Genau, mit der blogger vergessen. Und hier geht es weiter mit dafür auch draufklicken
Energieversorgung wird revolutioniert strom vom nachbarn da geht es. Um den stromhandel mit bock chains ansonsten bis. Dann
bleibt kann